lire des citoyens des États
-Unis ceci est un message d'anonyme au
département de police de Minneapolis auquel nous ne faisons pas
confiance ici à travers une fausse isation pour
rendre justice, nous allons donc exposer
vos nombreux crimes au monde
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup d'auto-  initiative donc
quiconque veut en quelque sorte créer une vidéo
au nom des anonymes peut le faire nous
sommes anonymes nous sommes légion nous ne
pardonnons pas nous n'oublions pas attendez nous
nous vous avons
observé vous n'avez nulle part où vous cacher
parce que nous sommes partout
[Musique]
il est difficile de dire où est le groupe mais
c'est définitivement un groupe clandestin de
gens très intelligents qui n'ont aucune
science informatique qui connaît le
fonctionnement d'Internet
[Musique]
plus de 20 000 comptes Twitter
appartenant à Isis viennent d'être supprimés
par des anonymes ce n'est que le début
Isis nous allons vous chasser supprimer les
emails de vos comptes sites et vous exposer
désormais n  o endroit sûr pour vous en ligne
[Musique]
fascinant à leur sujet, c'est que d'
une part il y a des formes de stabilité et de
cohérence d'autre part, ils
peuvent vraiment changer en fonction d'un nouvel
événement médiatique ou en fonction de l'endroit où ils
veulent eux-mêmes se prendre dans
le  avenir